tomorrow get off my stage right now hi
everyone I'm Mike McCarty back here with
Lucy James hey tomorrow saying hey and
Peter Brown hello tomorrow you've been
onstage Pete you've been toiling away
upstairs for most of the week that's a
question so this is just a lovely Peter
I said no more hours with this stage and
we want to get our money's worth so
we're hanging out and we're talking
about the games we were disappointing
sip of beer we're talk about the games
we we're disappointed not to cd3 or
maybe new wouldn't be here and just kind
of really want to see talk about where
they might be in development so yeah
let's jump into it it's an excuse to
talk about Sony basically yes um we can
start with Sony games
PE we're talking about ghosts of
Tsushima earlier today sushi mood yeah
that's [ __ ] done here do one at a
time because I'm earlier hired DuBose's
Tsushima what about I'm actually not a
big last of us guys so definitely I can
talk about ghosts Tsushima sucker-punch
was here last year they made a pretty
big showing and that game you know we've
seen quite a bit of it but yeah
obviously Sony's not here at all they
didn't give it any teases prior to the
show if they did for death training I
think I don't even know where the game
is in development doesn't have a release
window it doesn't have any sort of
release window
it exists one day you will play it
that's why do you think it'll be I
reckon it'll be out next year Paul yeah
no early early next year
he only gave me a launch title for five
across gen male if it comes out next
year I think he'll be crossed in yet if
it's late next year in question but yeah
all we've seen so far is that one like
mission they showed us and then that
faceoff at the end right yeah all right
that was last year in that horrible 10th
press conference thing that fiasco he
said horrible 10 press conferencing like
we were there we did you guys have to go
no to actually yeah we were pre-show
post show stuff yeah we did tech
rehearse all the time ask us things and
we were like the news is happening
I'm excited for that also in the sense
that more most like the grittiest thing
sucker-punch has done yeah I think it's
probably good that it's not soon because
I think it might be too close to secure
oh yeah and a bunch of other like
samurai like game oh this is like a Dark
Souls like yeah so I think I ain't
giving it some space
well you know I was jokingly saying you
were comparing it to a Dark Souls game
anyway jokes have to be funny
I tell the pumpkin joke yeah this looks
good though this is again this is like
the only mission we've seen it starts
off a little bit of self but then fights
off these dudes yeah again it's it's
it'll be interesting to see how a Sucker
Punch tackles it after infamous with
super comic book II and you like were
violent in a goofy way outside a ghost
Tsushima Pete you mentioned last part -
ha does one here have a head they said
when to bring that out no no everyone
has fumes at 2019 or at least they were
I
I reckon PlayStation experience will get
a release date oh but not be Paris games
what else would they talk about there oh
lord please don't do our person they've
done a bunch of Last of Us stuff at
Paris games week where last year's when
they had the mega violent gameplay
trailer I wouldn't be surprised if I
reckon parent not Paris games week
PlayStation experience is going to be
Sony's e3 this year they all have a
release date for Last of Us and then I
think they might have something more
significant than tech specs for
PlayStation 5 you would hope so I would
hope so yeah if we don't win PlayStation
experience is it's actually gonna be one
I don't think but there wasn't one last
year right exactly so it didn't have
anything yeah I think it just makes
sense for it to be this year if only to
clear the table of all the existing
stuff that they want to get out of way
stuff like ghosts of Tsushima which
maybe next gen that could maybe stay out
but like for certainly for loss of us I
reckon
they want to get ahead of that and kind
of because right now PlayStation 4s kind
of coasting right it's just like fine
with third-party games there's nothing
made your first party on the horizon
that we know has a definite release date
I'm probably forgetting some game death
yeah yeah that's trending is the one I
guess but like they've got more in
development they could be giving us a
day for and that seems like the best
place to do it where they can own the
message I don't think that weird
Nintendo Direct things are kind of
hitting the way that they want them to
they usually what like two minutes or
something like that I mean like the
first one could have been a lot better
but they did good by following up with
both deaths training and Final Fantasy 7
right yeah I guess what a big show what
the first one it was mostly VR and
Ironman VR which really isn't anything I
mean I don't know I played a little bit
of it and it's good but it's really not
all that special
so to lead with that to open up your
yeah it'll be weird so I reckon
yeah PlayStation experience some sort of
big event where they kind of give the
PlayStation 4 a bit of a send-off while
also announcing well also asking you to
keep keep buying it keep on until
holiday 2020 or whatever they're gonna
do PS 5 the last most part she was so
weird for me because although in theory
I'm excited for it the Last of Us I just
there's one of those games or I didn't
need a sequel and I don't think I've
ever really gotten excited for part two
I'm sure once it's about to come out
I'll play it you know hopefully like it
but I don't know every time I think
about it I'd have to kind of force
myself a very huge Naughty Dog fan you
know yeah you don't have any sense of
just I am but like oh yeah yeah but I
wasn't really like excited uncharted 4
and then I go like I said it's nothing
to say in part to his quality I played
all part two already behind closed off
wait well while we're here talking about
Sonjia you mentioned death stranding we
saw a lot more of that super weird game
recently yep yeah yeah tell me about it
do you okay be honest do you know what
Kojima means when he says oh it's a
social strand game no yes
what does he mean it's more of a feeling
I can't explain it's like you just have
to know when you're a kijima fine and
you played enough Metal Gear you just
feel it in your bone
do you this is kind of an unfair
question do you think that now that he
just got free rein to do whatever
that'll help the game in a good way or
could that potentially be like too
limitless
I don't think he this is his first
opportunity to do exactly what he wants
I would love to see what he's been
waiting to do if that is indeed what des
training is like why not just let him go
all out if that's happening I think
that's going to the gameplay that
remains to be seen in the story but I'm
tell he's been eking towards using more
and more celebrities in his games I was
specifically you know Keith we get it
you have cool friends Kojima people -
Nicolas Winding reference I mean like I
don't think he's as unbridled as people
think he is like that game is funded in
part by Sony - oh yeah like that that's
that doesn't mean he's got free rein to
do what they want whatever he wants
they'll go I don't I don't know about I
don't know I reckon Sony will be like
relax I think like Sony is the has the
power that Konami wishes it wish it
could have had to exert over Kojima but
he was Konami he was everything so now
that he's gone he has the space to make
more of what he wants which means not
Metal Gear I wouldn't be surprised if
they put him on a rough timeline yeah I
don't know if creatively they're like
looking over his shoulder and being like
okay that's that's too much I mean like
the nonsense concepts that he comes up
with I'm sure he's had like hundreds of
them over the last few years of
development and they've had to at least
knock out a few of them
he's got social strand gaming out there
I'm not saying they're like every single
thing he's coming up with ends up there
I'm sure he also has his own reflection
and things are not fit but I just gotta
be frivolous stuff it's in there just
because he's like why the hell not yeah
I mean obviously that what that's what
makes a Kadima game right yeah yeah do
you think like I guess well you're the
kind of touched on it but I don't know I
wonder if he it's gonna be one of the
things with without an editor unless you
what you say is happening is happening
and there is someone looking over her
shoulder which I agree with you I don't
think is the case I wonder if there is
nobody I'd like to see him be untethered
give him no bounds
just curious as a Dennis joke I mean
there he has done that before and it's
it's always resulted in games that are
interesting though not exactly
exceptional stuff like you know boktai
and and various other games we don't
know what those came from right like
those could have been like mandates of
his employment for all we know yeah
those are just those are very different
from what we know him for right in
general in terms of something really
great is happening over there yeah I
don't know I'm I'm willing to let him
just do what he wants to do what that
looks like
let joaquim Ogrin make whatever he wants
that's what I'm saying
Norman Reedus I was hearing someone say
Norman Reedus
like this Norman fetus Norman fetus yeah
man fetus Kojima and Guillermo del Toro
I think it was during a BAFTA Awards met
up backstage just to like congratulate
each other or something
I don't it might not even be met even in
bathtub but apparently they're all in
the same room and none of their
translators are there I like I think
hajima speaks decent English in person
you can understand more than he
understands more than he lets on yeah
but either way like all three of them
were speaking different languages
congratulating each other and I fire
like laughing and shaking hands even if
that didn't happen I like the image of
it jaqen they've got a group chat a
whatsapp group there but like I imagine
Norman Reedus is always in there and he
reads everything but he never replies
probably a discord called dirty Kojima
and the boys and kijima only responsible
selfies he doesn't actually ever type
anything it's always a selfie just only
this picture of food anything else from
Sony
no I mean the ps5 I guess yeah I guess
so yeah PlayStation 5 is a big one
obviously weren't gonna be here I was
hoping that a blood-borne two would
materialize but sadly not did you see
that zoom the one Incredibles you know
was gonna what Connie was responsible
for that I from the corner of my eye
it's Jake decker 2 over here yeah so I
don't know it's one of those cases where
I wonder if the project scarlet
announcement did anything to light a
fire under so he's flustered they'd
probably already have the Year planned
out yeah I think that how much of an
announcement was that really yeah I
don't know you got your the tech guy it
it wasn't really an announcement it
wasn't it was more of it a lot of
loading times gonna be shorter duration
of what they're doing rather than for
the motion exactly thing about is the
project scarlet name right
the name as in like they're not saying
in terms of some identity for whatever
it is yeah like it's not I mean the
Scotland nebulous next console it is
yeah it's it's it's the idea for their
vision for the next generation which is
a family of devices that is kind of like
bringing together community of Xbox
gamers so I think everyone went in
looking for a unit to be shown and
absolutely no one got an absolute unit
was not shown so I think people and like
I think Sony has almost got the jump on
them and announced the same things that
Scarlett did so like Scarlett the
scholar discussion was about hard drives
and RAM which Sony did like months ago
right yeah so it kind of I think it's a
somehow sony has stealing a stolen a bit
of the Thunder from Microsoft in advance
I reckon I mean I just yeah if you want
to call it thunder I don't know if
either one is really that thunderous
yeah and these one PlayStation did do
was give when they were talking to Wired
a demonstration of things right and what
they were able to relay that information
to us so it was almost like the
experience is something that we were
able to get some insight into we don't
have any insight into whatever Scarlett
is now this is a trend that I really
dislike I'm gonna get a bit upset on
stage for like don't talk about tech
and numbers and stuff without showing
some sort of on those micro processors
yeah it's like oh we can do this in a K
and it can run out 120 frames for what I
mean is that what yeah what what does
that exist as like I know at least Sony
did the spider-man thing to help people
visualize what that means and see it and
and they kind of released our video
later on or not officially but I go out
there perhaps Oh with the puddles huh is
that the puddle thing or is that just
the initial spike oh no the spider-man
swinging thing where I rendered the city
fast Microsoft just said it runs in a K
and has 120 and can do 120 frames per
second and that was it and there's no
loading times or they're almost
non-existent yeah that's not like to
most people that's nonsense
like I played blood-borne how about play
blood-borne yeah yeah those loading
times sucked when I first came out it
did yeah scarlet no load I mean let's
give her to those games missing from e3
time you mentioned you I mean
blood-borne - hasn't been announced so
doesn't exist in my in any physical form
here which is this point like I mean we
got olden ring elders ring owned elders
ring and we got elder ring but I'm still
kind of holding out for a true sequel to
blood-borne I know Mike's would probably
won that as well but I don't know maybe
it made sense for it to happen but now
that we know that Eldon ring is a
Miyazaki game that doesn't seem like
there's a natural timeline where he
would have been able to work on it which
is a shame that he's moved on tails a
ring so seemingly so quickly it's like
Nomura be just seeming he never has a
holiday yeah dip in between projects I
think there's a possibility that they
have elven ring is earlier in
development than a blood-borne two they
just announced Elden ring because Game
of Thrones is still yeah maybe maybe
there's like I do feel like they had
they had Dark Souls and blood-borne and
then they announced a hero that close
out Dark Souls and blood-borne sake hero
they announced
Elden ring one more to which the logical
next step
then that weird week I mean like
blood-borne the first game was like
early in the ps4 launch cycle right
thank you 15 years so maybe it's the
case of like once the PlayStation 5 has
been established that's when they come
out and they say yes we're actually
working on this game there's going to be
a blood-borne 2 and you know it will be
out XYZ window on a playstation 5 in
which case that's fine I would have
liked to have seen some sort of signs of
life from that game but you know
Elden ring is a good consolation prize
yeah other games missing Need for Speed
they announced it and they were like
yeah that's a need for speed coming in
2019 and then all right cool bye he's
had a very interesting year I'd say yeah
I mean I was gonna bring up anthem it
was missing for me free I mean it had 30
seconds net minder that games just be
the Cataclysm event is a test server
yeah which people already don't like
especially people have grinded a lot I
get it it's the opposite of what
Bethesda did with 76 Todd came on stage
talking about it and he said I mean
obviously that was a lot longer after
the release it was a year after 76 this
is only three and a half months after
anthem right but something about games
coming up here like destiny it was up
here warframe is up here all these
ongoing game yeah well I was over word
that anthem wasn't here where was the
voice that was missing from e3 we could
have done have a word appear have a word
with Randy next year oh no problem
overwatch yeah it's gonna be okay but
yeah I mean like the Need for Speed
thing was really weird to me because in
previous years they have like they've
always brought it showing it off it's
usually looked pretty good yeah I know
about it I don't know what state they're
Need for Speed franchises in right now
cuz they had like the last year have
been a bit rough right last game was bad
yeah real live action cutscene i think
that i think i think just called neither
speed they need to go back to
underground bring back unusually
it really did peek at that time yeah I
think I mean a hot pursuit was really
good as well but Leia the underground
stuff was the graduation from all of
that and it became something fun and
light-hearted and now it's always trying
to be serious again a need for speed it
doesn't work as a serious game yeah need
to be EA's forethe right in terms of
simulations yeah it doesn't need to be
fast and furious Eva but it does trying
to do that I mean that's not what
underground was right underground wasn't
fast and furious it was like a
ridiculous other kind of yeah it was a
graduated form of that yeah so like they
need to go I think they need to go back
to that and people will be excited about
it again but they I don't have a large
degree of tracer they will be able to
capture some sort of unique tone to it
again you might have missed
mister kind of opportunity now racing
games as a whole like there's only a
couple that can really survive and exist
in the mainstream Burnett was super
popular right and there's been sort of
like revivals from the team that are at
least the lead creative behind the
burnout series at his new company three
fields entertainment yeah and those
games are just not good like I just I
feel like the racing landscape has
changed so much that I'd be room for
this many different racing who would
have thought that the predominant racing
game genre would be caught races in this
day and age right yeah like the
strongest racing games all usually car
racers no no I mean that's underselling
reports the series quite a bit which is
right in the races with Lego another
getting along not a long line second in
a line of weird DLC s cool but weird
yeah hot wheels from Forza horizon 3
yeah so all the games were missing me
three my best girl buy an extra three
she's not yeah yeah one of the creatives
was at e3 saying like we're working on
the game the reason to sign here is
because we're working on the game it's
progressing we're going all out on it I
mean yeah it's always gonna say that but
at least there was something said to be
like no it's still happening so yeah but
it wouldn't but you know to hear
something as good what else is platinum
doing right now than you've had we had
them on today right yeah yeah they're
working what babylons fall oh yeah
missing another game here at e3 x-files
where is it yeah aspartame looks good it
looks like one of the crazier games it's
the guy who was one of the key creatives
on Nier automata doing his own project
yeah and it does look really really
interesting but yeah Boehner definitely
missing yeah the last year but like I
that's gonna be around soon like that
we'll get it on Nintendo Direct I think
exactly yeah I think it's one of those
games is like giving a more intimate
look a is what the fans want yeah so
they'll do that for sure
anything else Square Enix uh well allow
me to check these any new Legacy of Kain
games the pre-show I was like tough time
if he were here would be asking about
there's no Soul Reaver in announced in
many many years Square Enix continuing
to waste their time with other games
that aren't legacy of kain final fight
was another game in the universe a
couple years ago that was all scoff yeah
yeah no scar it actually was gave it was
okay yeah like down fairly quick right
yeah that was our time when people had
like a lot less patience for games that
weren't immediately doing well like you
started off in a promising way and then
they started improving it and then that
kind of like patience ran out and they
just Shia down yeah and he did have a
quite a few good like links back to the
main Legacy of Kain series like Rafael's
clan were in there if I remember
correctly and it was really really
interesting because a more you play
games I know exactly what you want but I
think like there's a lot of like back
there's a lot that can be done with the
Legacy of Kain franchise it's so rich in
law and like it was if I had a dream
pairing like give that to from software
and my god
like the combat is already very similar
to the way Dark Souls is and that
lock-on star strafing combat and like
world building and creation and temporal
phase it's shifting
and oh my god from stuff we're making a
legacy of kain Soul Reaver a sequel it
would kill me on sight if you reading a
body race really quick to go off the
topic of the panel my dream marriage
probably would have been Larian and
baldur's gate 3 so that's pretty crazy
that's happening yeah I'm happy former
reviews either Kevin or it gets to write
and baldur's gate yeah but anyway sorry
that's game I was happy to see here yeah
what else
so you've just I've had a couple of key
games missing like skullenbones yes
skullenbones weird so like Dave I know
played it to last year went to see if
the eaves and skullenbones were the
pirate games
well obviously see if these was coming
out soon but we talked about that in the
pre-show we're like you think though I
think they kind of said they weren't
gonna show it but also what's going on
with it that's Ubisoft Singapore yeah
last we heard about it they were
expanding some of the content so I think
they might've liked this the the thing
you we every one's reading into it is
like the ship-to-ship combat probably
wasn't enough and they're like building
is some sort of more meaty campaign
around it yeah like that's not confirmed
I don't know so many also since they
announced it they've gotten the division
has improved so much and those games
that service have done so many new
things
since skullenbones announced I wonder if
they said maybe rather than launch this
and then build on it we could kind of
find s it for a while maybe they're
watching to see what see if thieves is
there was Microsoft's gonna do foresee
it feeds from their time right they're
coming back see if teams like it's not
like a I don't think it's a marvelous
game but like hates no wolfram it
presents great position it presents
really great potential right it just
needs material it's a sort of eke a
potential out got like two million
players in the last three months I think
something yeah on the stage last night
Joe and Mike and we're just talking
amongst each other for about an hour is
awesome it needs to be here and I know
like ninja I think or crowd one of them
started streaming it in January and they
were number 1 on twitch for like three
months in a row which is huge
actually over like League and everything
yeah
but outside of yes skullenbones is such
a weird entity because before Black Flag
came out amazing yeah I would love the
naval combat
we need to get into its own game the SAS
before had so many things it was an
assassin's Creed game so I had a formula
that they can put that into skullenbones
sort of an unknown quantity and its
overall structure I'm just really
curious about what its gonna be beyond
good and evil to this in the II was a
pre-show ie that game continues to be a
myth in it like just doesn't I'm really
happy for Ian she's excited for that
who's excited that I got announced and I
don't get what that game is yeah I don't
know like what are the measuring behind
that game is baffling and like it feels
like someone needs to step in and just
say is this a game you're making or not
I feel quite cynic in me says that it
was an it was a different project yeah
the vendee stuff happened and they
slapped can't be a prince of persia'
can't be an XYZ let's just make it a
beyond good Eve I like the whole like
you can make content and then it's gonna
be in the game it's like mmm no you make
the call you have to wonder like okay is
that like what they're leading with or
is that just a thing that they're saying
is also in addition to that could just
maybe be scrapped if it's not working
out but I mean like for this in the
pre-show but microstrain concerns about
how people and obviously there was a
huge uproar about how people will be
credited and we're not credit get money
back for it because if you think about
the way that dreams does it they have a
really deep system of if you make one
thing and it's used in someone's level
someone's dream you're credited if
someone then takes that dream and
remixes it and you know it goes up a
chain you are always still credited as
being the person you made that one
particular thing but then at the same
time you are still making it for free
you're not getting reimbursed for your
time or anything but I mean some people
want that just you know to create and
put it out there but it's
I don't I don't know what Beyond Good
and Evil 2 is I don't understand how
it's connected at all yeah I mean they
said what that it was a divisive there
was a prequel and then Jade was in it
but they said a lot of things that made
no sense to me and then when I was about
to ask a question they were like check
out the all work we've got I was like
actually I'd like to know about like no
check out the all work we got I don't
swear
irritating monkey did a weird tonal
establishment really good evil the
original game was so wholesome and just
you know it was also I got like it
yeah it's like a Disney wholesome
there's all those a culture there even
soft it was so missing witness hell yeah
well yeah but hockey was on stage but
not for Splinter Cell Office myself I
mean wow how silent they are about that
franchise yeah it's like they know we
want it they just tease us they did that
weird tweet they talked about a bunch of
developers being in the same place
working on a Splinter Cell right
[Music]
they did announce
backwards-compatibility this week right
yeah yeah I mean like yes valuable
valuable I guess and it does maybe
they're watching like to see how many
people actually take them up on
backwards compatibility for Splinter
Cell and it's probably ended I mean it's
ended on there right yeah it's gotta be
in development but I mean how long can
you go before people are just like fine
whatever leave it yeah yeah I mean any
of you play blacklist yeah Oh game was
great I mean all the Splinter cells are
good I'm like this is such a fertile
ground now with so many so few
blockbuster stealth games but yeah I
think we're about goose and explain
yourself I just hope it's soon that we
get to see something about and like
weird-looking Sam Fisher in a weird
mobile games not enough we do have like
a minute left unfortunately half-life 3
where is it you're probably know
Rocksteady all right Rockies I know this
you're gonna give me [ __ ] but I'm
serious I was kind of hoping Jake
Salomon was showed up and said XCOM how
are you going that's coming it's gonna
be here
especially now that sip six has such
strong expansions the other side of
Firaxis must be like ready and serious
of course it's gonna get a sequel you
know no I'm not trying to sound
intelligent I'm saying I wish it was
like kind of a tease here Assassin's
Creed I would have liked to have seen
even like a team because I could see new
one
you got the dirt Chris I didn't know
this game steady
well Rock Steady's elite squad oh yeah
well Rocksteady doing
Harry Potter no oh that's W that I don't
know that's Rocksteady I think
Rocksteady gonna be keeping with Batman
DC they said there was it wasn't
Superman there's been rumors about
Damian Wayne games about birds of prey
Superman I mean pick your Deezy poison
piston hill though for tweeting the
exact same thing he tweeted last year he
won the two words I was like now we're
not gonna be here and it comes every
year copy and paste is that that's a
huge Russell he did a game award and
like people are genuinely upset that
Rocksteady like angry about this video
suvai online like where are Rocksteady
the more ate yeah my in a way that they
have all this time to make whatever
they're making I mean all the way it's
that's good news I mean you make that
call come series like surely Warner
Brothers is like they take as much time
as you want no shadow for was I mean
like shadow board II and performed by
the Batman series did Arkham Knight just
came to campus right yeah Arkham Knight
is on underrated game I can optimize
great it had some drama with the PC
version but Arkham Knight is a fantastic
game I think it's got one of the best
stories in the in their series see you
see I know Asylum is the best asylum
right we are actually out of time we are
going to have to arm rent some other
sites
we're gonna have friends from other
sites on stage got Greg Miller we have
Mary Kish we have Brandon Jones coming
on stage in a mere matter of minutes
stick around we'll see you then this is
the last thing in the show so don't go
anywhere bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]